[Music]
so elena like one of elena's best
friends
uh one of our friends
he's gay and he's telling
us about
this [ __ ] website
sniffy's yeah you just go to
sniffies.com
dude
gay guys are playing fortnite in real
life it's a [ __ ] map and people just
post their pin oh and it just says what
they want to do you know
there was one guy who put a pen he says
casual he's like he's like
what is it sniffy's sniffies so sounds
like a uh
like a nose strip yeah yeah snoopy's
like a lottery ticket
[Laughter]
so bro he
he posts like this particular guy says
he labels his pen
and he gives instructions and it has
very detailed you know instructions of
what he's looking for you know what it
what is a problem so for him he was
saying pull up
pump me full of [ __ ]
don't take too long make it quick right
and join the line
there was a line so bro there was a
[ __ ] cue
like for him
it showed all these users who were
queued up to go [ __ ] him and i was dying
i'm like these guys are just cueing
solos on this guy's [ __ ] yeah
and so then we're just looking at the
map like this is crazy you just pin
like reply and then it's just yep okay
it's like craigslist
yes but the the interactive map part of
it was so funny to me because i'm like
this is fortnite like this where are we
dropping boys
and i just remembered that it's in real
life so they really are going to go yes
bang him yeah and he's like you're my 2
215 yeah yeah no it'll say like in
probably a little bit
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah no it'll like
it has like a status yeah i'm a little
bit i got pumped a little too full let
me just no bro it has a status like
banging it says like in progress or like
opening like a pizza tracker yeah dude
that's [ __ ] crazy didn't you just hop
up
you're on the you're on the fortnite
your pump is being dumped
it's in the oven
yeah pumping
eyes pumping right now
dumping oh we should be next
yeah bro that's [ __ ] crazy we were
just la we're all laughing like i'm like
we could just go out as a squad right
now yeah let's uh oh let's go [ __ ] this
guy like together yeah that's funny so
we did and yeah yeah how was that nice
looking hole that i can pump yeah just
open my app here why was it brought up
because uh our buddy he's always clueing
us into
just
like gay culture he even he was shocked
he goes oh dude he just like stops the
conversation he's like i have to show
you this like what is it he's like
sniffy's it's the craziest [ __ ]
website and he was right yeah so it's
like it's like grindr but just like
strip away all the [ __ ] yeah like
it's not even about communication right
that's how i say it's like a game right
because you're just like oh yeah
south la it's like it looks like a gta
map yeah it's like pokemon go yeah it
just has like a little circle with a pin
and it'll be like a picture of a guy
spreading his ass and what's that about
pull up bring your friends crazy
but so there was one that had me dying
laughing it was just a thing for a
kickback
but it was just naked
and so i was laughing at the idea of all
these people being naked and one guy
being weird and then like the chads of
the party coming up to just butt ass
naked like bro you got a dip yeah like
you're [ __ ] okay yeah yeah just like
getting kicked out naked is so funny
putting his pants on and [ __ ]
yeah yeah he's like well i'm just i'm
sorry he's like bounce dude put your
[ __ ] clothes on and go it's like you
would be i was gonna say like if we were
all naked noah will still come up to me
and be like why is your body like a
substitute teacher
[Laughter]
man
you look like [ __ ]
i took the substitute teacher clothes
off
yeah yeah but what's under it is also
something to a teacher
yeah a whole party is like yeah bros
giving it's giving biology
it's giving biology man
bro
one one last thing yeah that was just i
don't know where you're gonna go now
yeah
no i was just also laughing at like
getting roped into a shitty conversation
that you have at a party but you're
naked so it's just worse yeah like the
music's hella loud and someone's like so
what do you do for work [ __ ]
no can't put hands in pockets
yeah you can't do [ __ ]
you can't [ __ ] like
i do
awkwardly just touching your balls like
yeah
thank you for saying ball
thank you
yeah
awkwardly just touching your balls
you for saying paul
thank you no problem yeah
you're just stretching out your one nut
i work for a social media
team
yeah yeah
yeah i'm really apparently my hr is
going to show up here
all these are real real haunting fears
yeah just just i'm sorry
what do what do you do for oh your
sister does what are you going to drink
my piss or what's good
no it's not even sexual because the
guy's just annoying yeah yeah oh you're
working that's sick man
yeah i've always wanted to start a nap
you know i should tell you about it i
have an idea yeah
yeah it's called sniffy's
[Laughter]
i was saying it could be like this but
it's not like an interactive map you
know you play fortnite right
he's like [ __ ] dude
just suck my dick or something what are
we doing here
what's your hangout though that's not
working yeah it's true yeah or you're
you're the one who shows up with your
clothes on and everyone makes you feel
weird about it yeah and you have to like
awkwardly like get undone i'll probably
show up with clothes i would feel
uncomfortable yeah yeah i feel like any
of us right
yeah dude
cool yeah noah has a sniffy's pin set up
right now people are going through the
door
so
we started laughing about that and alina
and i were saying dude you could just
like
drive around your neighborhood and just
set up a pin somewhere and just say some
[ __ ] like yo pump and dump hole i'm
trying to get a hundred guys in here and
you just bounce
you just got dudes knocking on the door
like
yeah i'm
the first one they would find some way
to have fun for sure yeah
but like you know still a lot of holes
to be pumped around here so gay people
come up with the best words for products
yeah like sniffy's is [ __ ] great
grinder is great genius poppers is great
yeah like what why do straight people
it's like eharmony
because we're stupid tinder
straight people are are very literal
tmg's great
you guys did a good job
damn okay okay thank you clapping back a
little bit okay
okay shut the hell up [ __ ] go kill
yourself go sit in the middle of the
road imagine the comments who are like
yeah i don't know i kind of see why they
wrote zach like he piped up that one
time
yeah yeah yo mid mid-roast dude
zach kind of ruined it
i just hope it's 300 comments of like
who's the one nut guy
you